simona amores is taking the new opel
courser out for a test drive
the fifth generation of this perennial
best seller comes across as young
dynamic and restyled
today zimona is putting the new opel
corsa through its paces
and what is her first impression
she says the new opel corsa drives
really well
it's a very pleasant ride
there are always situations where you
have to get off to a fast start at the
stoplight and for that the engine lacks
a bit of pickup but once it's up to
speed it drives very smoothly
she says the tight steering ratio makes
it fun to drive and allows for easy
maneuvering
she's very positively surprised and says
it handles wonderfully
the new corsa boasts the same
three-cylinder turbocharged gasoline
engine with direct fuel injection that
opel fans remember from the adam
the test car is powered by a one liter
engine with an output of 85 kilowatts
fuel consumption is rated at 4.9 liters
of premium per hundred kilometers with
extras this color edition corsa lists at
20 085 euros in germany
explains that their aim was to make the
engine imperceptible so nobody would
notice the cars running on three
cylinders to do so they offset the mass
with a balance shaft so it produces less
vibration than many four-cylinder
engines do
starting in 1982 the quarter has been
assembled in saragosa spain and
eisenhower in eastern germany the fifth
generation will soon be appearing on
showroom floors across europe
the new opel corsa has been thoroughly
redesigned to lend its sleeker contours
but an overall beefier look and
harmonious lines to enhance its
sportiness
all the while the courser preserves its
familiar profile
buyer of opel explains that what car
makers call signatures are essential
here
a recurring motif for example are the
creases on the hood close to the front
it's a signature you can see on the
older cars of the first generations
the same goes for the side profile where
you see the sickle down below
opel places enormous value on having
this signature appear precisely there
a mark of quality
and
the interior has also had a makeover
giving it lots of space
gentle curves bi-colored accents soft
fabrics and comfortable seats with
improved lateral support
an optional 7-inch color touch screen
can be tucked in between the driver and
passenger featuring the intellilink
infotainment system
we opened the bring go navigation app
and waited
and waited
a good 52 seconds
until it was ready for use
the new course's rear seats also have
plenty of space the arched roof gives
even tall passengers the head and leg
room they need
the cargo hatch doesn't skimp either the
split rear seat provides ample space in
back
opel is aiming the new corsa directly at
young active women like simona amores so
what does she think
on the whole she likes the new opel
corsa a lot saying it handles nicely
it's nimble and pleasant
forward visibility is a bit impaired by
the car's long front
and the app restricts the navigation
system's operation a bit but otherwise
it's a great car perfect for the city
and pleasant to drive
perfect
it's attractive
thoroughly
networked and equipped with the latest
safety technology
the new opel corsa available in german
showrooms from december starting at 11
980 euros
you